I THINK MS. WEISS IS CORRECT.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE SAME SMEAR
TACTICS WE’VE SEEN.
JOINING IS NOW WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY
KAYLEIGH McENANY.
LET ME SAY IT’S A BADGE OF HONOR
FOR YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS THEY DON’T LIKE
YOU.
I THINK, I CELEBRATE THAT.
WANT TO GO TO ONE PIECE.
YOU KNOW, BROUGHT UP THAT YOU
DON’T WANT TO WORK WITH
REPORTERS.
CAN THEY FIRST APOLOGIZE FOR THE
YEAR’S WORTH OF LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES ON RUSSIA
BEFORE WE WORK WITH PEOPLE THAT
ARE UNWILLING TO TELL THE TRUTH
THEMSELVES AND DON’T RETRACT AND
APOLOGIZE QUESTION MARKS BECAUSE
THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
INSTEAD OF RETRACTING THOSE
STORIES, THEY WON PULITZERS.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" FOR LYING
ABOUT THE WITCH HUNT AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THEY WERE DEAD WRONG BUT THEY
DON’T APOLOGIZE.
THEY DON’T.
WHAT’S SO EGREGIOUS ABOUT THIS
IN PARTICULAR WITH THE
TOM COTTON OP-ED, WE USED THE
BRIEFINGS AND WE HAD PEOPLE
WHOSE NAMES ARE NOT MENTIONED IN
MANY MAINSTREAM PUBLICATIONS,
LIKE DAVID DORN, THE POLICE
OFFICER WHO LOST HIS LIFE AND
THE RIGHTS AND HOW IRONIC THAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" RATHER THAN
HIGHLIGHTING THIS TRAGIC STORY
THAT DESERVES ATTENTION THEY
INSTEAD CENSOR A PIECE THAT
MENTIONS AND TALKS ABOUT THE
VIOLENCE AND THE RIOTS AND THAT
OF COURSE IS
SENATOR TOM COTTON’S OP-ED.
IT’S REALLY EGREGIOUS.
>> Sean: THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED, KAYLEIGH.
RUSH LIMBAUGH, SYNDICATED IN
1988, 200 TALK STATIONS.
THE NUMBER ONE FORMAT AND RADIO.
3,000 NOW AM AND FM.
THE PRESIDENT HAS 200 AND I
DON’T KNOW THE TOTAL TERMS OF
TWITTER, INSTAGRAM, FACEBOOK.
OVER 200 PLUS MILLION PEOPLE.
HE CAN GO DIRECTLY TO.
HE DOESN’T NEED THEM.
YOU HAVE MANY AND TALK RADIO.
I SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT’S
POLICIES OPENLY.
I DON’T HIDE IT AND I’M PROUD OF
HIS COMPLIMENTS.
YOU DON’T REALLY HAVE TO TALK TO
THESE PEOPLE ANYMORE.
I DON’T THINK THE PRESIDENT
NEEDS TO EVER ARGUE WITH THEM
AGAIN.
IT’S A WASTE OF TIME.
>> YOU’RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT’S WHAT DRIVES THEM NUTS.
YOU HAVE THE DEMOCRATS WHO
ENGAGE IN BASKET OF DEPLORABLE
POLITICS LIKE HILLARY CLINTON.
WHERE ARE ALL IN THE BASKET OF
DEPLORABLE SPRAY
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAYING
IT’S MORE THAN HALF OF THE
COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE THE MEDIA DOING THE
WORK OF THE LEFT AND IT DRIVES
THEM NUTS THAT THIS PRESIDENT
SPOKE DIRECTLY TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
MORE THAN 200 MILLION FOLLOWERS
IN THE DIRECT CONNECTION TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT’S WHAT DRIVES THEM TO BE EVEN
MORE INSANE IN THEIR COVERAGE OF
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: YOU COMING WITH A
BINDER AND YOU KNOW WHEN IT’S A
DIFFERENT TOPIC, YOU’RE
ALLOWED TO HAVE NOTES.
IT’S NOT LIKE A PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE, ALTHOUGH WHY DO I
SUSPECT THAT JOE BIDEN’S TEAM IS
GOING TO WANT NOTES IN THE
DEBATES WITH DONALD TRUMP IF HE
EVEN SHOWS UP TO TRY TO SET THE
STAGE THAT HE WOULDN’T.
THAT TO ME IS LIKE CHECKMATE.
THEY DON’T LIKE BEING CALLED OUT
OUT.
DOES NOT RELIEVE THE TRUTH?
>> THEY DON’T LIKE PREPARATION.
THEY DON’T LIKE THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS THE FACTS ON
THEIR SIDE.
WHEN THEY COME IN WITH A
QUESTION DESIGNED TO ATTACK THIS
PRESIDENT IN AN UNFAIR MANNER
AND THEN WE COME BACK WITH THE
FACTS AND WE SHOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER,
IT CERTAINLY DRIVES THEM NUTS
BUT THAT’S THE THING WITH THIS
PRESIDENT.
THE FACTS ARE ON HIS SIDE.
HE HAS DONE GREAT WORK FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO HE CARES
DEEPLY ABOUT.
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY IS A GREAT
STORY OF SUCCESS.
>> Sean: SHATTERING RECORD LOW
ON EMPLOYMENT FOR EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP IN THE
COUNTRY, THE TRAVEL BAN IN
QUARANTINE AND SUBSEQUENT TRAVEL
BANS.
WE NEVER RAN OUT OF VENTILATORS,
DID WE?
THE COUNTRY RELIED ON THE
WHITE HOUSE.
ALSO DEFEATING THE CALIPHATE
THAT BIDEN AND OBAMA DIDN’T
DEFEAT.
CAN YOU NOW JUST TOTALLY BYPASS
THEM AND REALLY NOT EVEN HAVE TO
TALK TO THEM EXCEPT I MEAN I
GUESS IT’S GOOD YOU GO IN THERE.
HAVE A NICE CHAT EVERY DAY.
IT GETS ENTERTAINING BUT I DON’T
THINK THE PRESIDENT NEEDS THE
MEDIA AND I THINK THAT MINUTE HE
IS GONE, THEY ARE OUT OF
BUSINESS.
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
YOU LOOK AT THE RATINGS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS PRESS BRIEFINGS, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR
FROM THE PRESIDENT UNFILTERED.
YOU HAVE THE MEDIA SAYING YOU’RE
NOT DOING ENOUGH TESTING.
WE LEAVE THE WORLD AND TESTING.
YOU DON’T HAVE ENOUGH
VENTILATORS.
WE ARE SUPPLYING THE WORLD WITH
HE SPEAKS DIRECTLY TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OF THOSE
5:00 P.M. PRESS BRIEFINGS.
>> Sean: JOE WOULDN’T HAVE PUT
THE TRAVEL BAN IN AND DEMOCRATS.
DEMOCRATS IMPEACHING
DONALD TRUMP AT THE SAME TIME
THE PRESIDENT WAS DOING WHAT NO
OTHER PRESIDENT HAS DONE TEN
DAYS AFTER THE FIRST CASE.